[Música]
voy a tratar de traducir desde el oscuro
lenguaje financiero que es un plan
financiero personal vale os daré unas
pinceladas un plan financiero personal
tiene tres patas pero antes de
explicaros en qué consiste en estas tres
patas permitidme una pregunta algunos de
ustedes ha preguntado cuánto vale subida
el precio de su existencia bien vamos a
verlo cuánto cuesta una vida por el
hecho de vivir cuanto cuesta no cuánto
vale el valor es incalculable
cuánto cuesta supongamos que una persona
mínimo cero máximo 100 años supongamos
que los primeros 20 años tiene la suerte
de que su familia le sostiene supongamos
que va a morir a los 80 años sale que va
a tener que pagar el precio de su
existencia 60 años vale calculemos
cuánto puede ser una vida mínima de
subsistencia una mini una vida mínima
aquí en españa sería alojamiento unos
400 euros claro no es lo mismo barcelona
que zamora pero bueno nos hacemos una
idea comida unos 150 euros resto vestida
a transporte ocio otros 150 euros total
700 euros al mes si cogemos 700 euros al
mes por 12 meses por 60 años esto es lo
que vale una vida de subsistencia la
friolera de medio millón de euros
solo por existir esto lo que yo llamo el
concepto la deuda original vale
qué pasa si la vida es un poco más
normal una vida de 1400 euros al mes
bueno pues que ya nos vamos al millón de
euros y si la vida empieza a ser más
desahogada a partir de unos dos mil
euros al mes nos encontramos que
superamos el millón y medio de euros el
precio de vivir y porque les cuento todo
esto pues porque cuando ayudó a hacer
planes financieros personales mucha
gente me pregunta que por qué hay que
ahorrar que para qué sirve el ahorro
pues para esto
el ahorro es esto es pagarte tu
existencia tenerla ya preparada el
ahorro no es para el futuro el ahorro es
para mejorar el presente porque sabiendo
que ya tienes dispuesto una parte de lo
que vas a pagar por vivir ya lo tiene
resuelto que generas seguridad
tranquilidad y libertad
eso es el ahorro
hay otras personas
que ya tienen integrado el tema del
ahorro bueno el ahorro es la primera
pata del plan financiero personal ya la
tenéis
qué es el ahorro el ahorro se divide en
dos partes o inversiones financieras o
inversiones inmobiliarias ladrillo ser
propietario de ladrillo que son las
inversiones financieras dinero dinero en
el bolsillo dinero en el banco vino en
el colchón bonos acciones planes de
pensiones etcétera inversiones
financieras toda esta riqueza es el
palabro patrimonio algunos les molesta
patrimonio riqueza
el ahorro que tienes almacenado para
hacer frente a tu vida
una vez solucionado el ahorro tienes que
saber para qué ahorras este es otro de
los temas y las dificultades que se
plantean que muchas personas son capaces
de ahorrar lo tienen por costumbre pero
no saben por qué ni para qué por qué por
qué no priorizan
como no priorizan que hacen pues la
estrategia del avestruz no mira y no
miran cuánto les cuesta su vida cuánto
les cuesta el tiempo que tienen cuánto
le cuesta su vivienda etcétera y que
hacen organizan una vida
sin pensar sin hacer las cuentas
que buscan una realización profesional
vale pues se cogen un muy buen trabajo
en el centro de la ciudad les encanta
pero no están satisfechos del todo
porque no tienen suficiente tiempo para
dedicarle
buscan a lo mejor una realización
familiar en un entorno emocional no
están satisfechos porque le dedican
demasiado tiempo al trabajo está bien
pero bueno luego ocio bueno intentan
tener un poco de ocio tampoco estaban
del todo satisfechos y montan una vida
ensalada que es un poco de todo que muy
bonito pero no llena
algunas y si tienen la suerte que les
viene fantástico se puede alimentar
ensaladas
sino que tienen que hacer priorizar y
que es priorizar elegir elegir segunda
pata del plan financiero personal
elegir es el núcleo de un plan
financiero personal es el corazón y es
lo más difícil si no eliges es muy
difícil construir el resto ojo que me
llegó hasta aquí ahorrando que significa
elegir
elegir significa decidir
decidir es prescindir si tú no sabes de
qué prescindes tú no puedes decidir
estas son las dificultades para elegir
que tienes que tener claro a qué
renuncias
si no sabes a qué renuncias no sabes qué
estás eligiendo puedes elegir una
realización profesional
y pagar su precio cual es alto tiempo y
dedicación puedes elegir una realización
la primera dicho profesional después la
realización personal por ejemplo
actividades de baja remuneración que
tiene un alto salario emocional
qué le pasa a estas actividades te
podrán satisfacer mucho que no tienen
pocos ingresos ese es el precio
si te interesa está bien pero que sepas
cuál es su precio puedes decidir una
realización emocional a través de nada y
familiar vale eso requiere condiciones
materiales buenas y bastante tiempo y
dedicación o puedes elegir hacer dinero
si eliges hacer dinero pagas el precio
que es estrés angustia y no dormir por
las noches todo tiene su precio bien por
qué es tan difícil elegir
la mente no le gusta que elijamos no
quiere que consideramos que podemos
elegir que podemos decidir cómo queremos
vivir la mente como que ya viene
programada con una forma de vida
normalmente es la forma de vida de
fidelidad al modelo familiar eso qué
quiere decir que si en tu familia eran
funcionarios tu funcionario si tu
familiar en empresarios pues tú vas a
ser empresario si tu familia eran
artistas pues tu artista hay otra opción
que es el caso ve el anterior es el a
que es el opuesto
este es el rebelde el que está peleado
con su familia su familia de empresario
pues hace rockero
su familia es de funcionarios pues el
que es empresario es lo opuesto
normalmente la gente no se cuestiona
porque vive esa vida y mucho menos
cuánto le cuesta pues bien la respuesta
suele estar no en la ni en la ve que es
el blanco o el negro está en el gris y
el gris es en la opción c d e f g la
mente no las considera por eso esta es
la parte más difícil la de elegir cómo
quieres vivir hay que hacer el clic y
atreverse a cuestionarse en la cabeza
ejemplos
toni
profesor con plaza fija casado con dos
hijos decide ni más ni menos a los 45
años que la apuesta por la realización
profesional y cambio de profesión y
estudia medicina que se va a hacer
médico estamos hablando empezar a esto
la medicina con 45 años para acabar
ejerciendo los cincuenta y tantos que
hace asume el precio que lo realiza
coste brutal de tiempo de dinero de
desatención a la familia etcétera
pero que consigue ya ha acabado ya está
ejerciendo una alta satisfacción
personal porque ha pagado el precio
gustosamente por su realización
profesional otro ejemplo
silvia silvia tiene un micro apartamento
en el centro de barcelona y quiere ser
profesora de yoga problema como profe de
yoga solo gana 500 euros al mes y
entonces tiene que tener muchos trabajos
y vive estresada sin poder hacer lo que
quiere que hace coge pone en alquileres
un micro apartamento le dan 800 euros
tiene la suerte que está en el centro de
barcelona 800 euros del alquiler más 500
euros por sus clases de yoga 1300 se va
a vivir a un pueblo perdido por 200
euros al mes
y asume que baja barcelona dos días a la
semana en los que condensa sus clases
que pasa que en ese pueblo puede
disfrutar de la naturaleza puede
disfrutar del tiempo y puede disfrutar
dedicarse al yoga que es lo que le gusta
paga el precio consigue el beneficio y
se atrevió a cuestionarse su forma de
vida
otro ejemplo clara le gusta su trabajo
lo disfruta está cansada y le gustaría
bajar el nivel de estrés que hace se
monta un plan de ahorro en el que dice
bueno yo en seis años me voy a generar
el suficiente patrimonio ahorro como
para poder comprar tres meses de permiso
de vacaciones cada año le cambia la vida
además de las vacaciones que ya tiene si
añades tres meses de vacaciones todos
los años
sacrificio bueno 66 años apretando para
poder ahorrar estas son las cuestiones
de elegir vale una vez que ya se ha
elegido supongamos que queremos comprar
tiempo
como hace clara
vamos a ver primero el tiempo puede ser
caro o barato qué tiempo quieres comprar
si quieres comprar tiempo barato es para
hacer algo que no te cueste mucho dinero
construye tu algo escribe un libro o
léelo vete a un camping con tus hijos de
vacaciones tiempo barato tiempo caro me
quiero ir a un resort de cancún cuando
los gastos pagados bueno eso es bastante
más caro pregunta
cuánto dinero necesito para darme un mes
de vacaciones al año vamos a calcular lo
supo compró tiempo barato tiempo a
barato mil euros al año yo necesito que
mi patrimonio me genere mil euros al año
para toda la vida
si asumo una rentabilidad de mi
patrimonio del 4% anual obtengo que
necesito 25 mil euros
sorpresa no es mucho
veinticinco mil euros es lo que vale un
coche medio bueno que quieres cambiarte
de coche o un mes de vacaciones al año
vale y aquí llegamos a la tercera pata
del plan financiero personal y última
invertir porque porque si no sabes
invertir tú no te sacas un 4 por ciento
anual
ahora los depósitos están por debajo del
1040 algo te darán ahora si sabes
invertir es muy fácil sacarse un 4%
anual
no es nada ambicioso
problema la gente gente que escucha
palabra invertir parece que le entrara
urticaria un rechazo y no invertir no
sobre todo en el en el a la creativa
hippie nos vamos esto nunca yo me quiero
dedicar a lo creativo a lo espiritual a
lo elevado que bueno pues si no aprendes
a invertir que es el coste que tiene us
poder comprar tiempo no vas a comprar el
tiempo para montarte la vida que quieres
ojo y en el otro extremo me encuentro
empresarios en un 4 por ciento aprender
a invertir por un 4 por ciento llegaron
40 yo sé de negocios
esto es aburrido y mediocre desitjat o
sí pero para tu 40 no duerme por las
noches estás a punto que tener un ataque
al corazón y te ponen un bypass pues
empresario este 4% significa estar
relajado y mirar una vez al año
vale resumiendo
de qué se trata un plan financiero
personal de hacer las cuentas
es tan sencillo como eso hacer las
cuentas de cuánto te cuesta vivir de
cómo quieres vivir y de cuánto te cuesta
cómo te vas a pagar
hacer las cuentas es una idea muy
sencilla
no es nada innovadora
de hecho hacer las cuentas en lo que ya
hacían nuestros abuelos pero es que
ellos las hacían para sobrevivir porque
no llegaban a fin de mes cuál es la idea
revolucionaria que os presento que
podemos hacer las cuentas para mejorar
nuestra vida para cuestionarnos nuestra
forma de vida y plantearnos formas de
vida que hasta ahora no nos hemos
atrevido esa es la idea innovadora
esto es lo que en unas nuevas corrientes
de economía están hablando de bueno de
decrecimiento o de economía sostenible
quitar de un sitio para mejorar en otro
y bueno esto es lo que les he presentado
un plan financiero de personal muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]